le plan politique les élections
municipales en mars 2020 ce vendredi la
liste décidons ensemble à guyancourt
candidature participative pour le
scrutin dans la ville commencera à son
opération de porte à porte pour trouver
ses colistiers pour le symbole les
membres seront uniquement aux portes
comportant le numéro 20 en référence à
l'année de l'élection
une méthode de tirage au sort expliqué
par téléphone par le conseiller
municipal olivier paréja écouter tout le
monde et l'egypte il a participé il n'y
a pas de raison que le fait de déneiger
une ville de laon fait des projets dans
une ville soit limité à seulement une
partie des gens après chacun s'implique
à sa façon avec la disponibilité etc
mais mais tout le monde est légitime
surtout à un niveau communal
des propos recueillis par mathilde de
deux mises